it's it's because what your mom but it
still exists today though by the way
when you go back to the acting stuff you
know there's I have there's a lack of
self-worth for me lack of self-love that
I have for myself I mean there's still
[ __ ] that I deal with so Oh cuz gay
cuz as a good-looking white dude not
pointing to you right yeah well in the
room it's so weird because I think I put
this like oh you're a lot like me
mmm I said it's so weird I never see
good-looking white dudes they're not
good-looking but you're not - come on
you - come on guys anyway uh BAM yeah
it's because I guess can tuna can yeah
but like so in many ways you know and
and and um that's why I like you so much
because you do have these kind of like a
stand you up stand-up comedy like you
were [ __ ] saying me you're like you're
gonna do three minutes you're gonna do
five minutes but I might make you wait
oh my god I'd [ __ ] myself you would know
you know it terrifies me yeah terrifies
me that's like the ultimate
vulnerability oh yeah now when you drive
around town you see the billboard of
that you wanna yeah you know do you what
do you think to your song is it you can
you detach yourself from it but that's
you on the couch now I know but you
can't go that's me
part of I do I do that's me look I
[ __ ] by the way I was behind the
couch
you can just put me in Lindsay I'll tell
you why underneath one eye but I tell
you why
I don't give a [ __ ] about like the show
that's great I'm glad I'm on well you
know mmm great people you know Ellen
DeGeneres whole thing you know it's the
reason why I always want to be on a show
is to be on the Billboard so I can get
revenge on the people that write to show
people though
hey I'm killing it dude how much is it
to buy a billboard if you did your own
and it's just do it like three
billboards and a bhima's yeah yeah yeah
but I just don't like put the ABC on all
that stuff on it can you oh if I called
ABC like what is it gonna be just me
wait we should do a gofund now go find
me like a IndieGoGo I'm not doing it
desperate no I here's why Warner
Brothers an ABC to sanction a post or
one day maybe you're to a year three if
it continues just just put me in Lindsay
in it that's all
so I can get my revenge on I can tell
you the names I want revenge people go
hey you know I'm still in it what's up
you like it would be nice no here's what
I want and I know let me tell you
something I know I know you're in
cahoots with the top no look at me right
now with no [ __ ] beauty [ __ ] why
not okay they're in cahoots with the top
I know that you get emails from the
president of Warner Brothers Peter on
well he has emailed I get get you have
okay have you emailed back and forth
well then there's the [ __ ]
connection caucus there's the freeway
the open okay what do you you know I
don't need anything I'm just telling you
are this I don't want anything all right
but what I do just I want to suggest
something to you okay is it's a Warner
Brothers show correct correct if the
show continues yeah right
they're eventually gonna be on the side
of the Warner Brothers yes
right yes now what I notice is in Mike
and Molly yeah when they did that poster
right
they showed nine people on it okay like
the whole cast right just you just think
about just listen just think about I
just need to be on that right there's a
good chance that could happen though I
know but I don't want to ask because
that's weird
let me throw it out the reason why is
because that wrote was a Barham are so
many comedians because it's first
there's the flapper bride so a lot of
comedians will go around that band and
it's gonna strike so much pain in a lot
of people but they could just see my
face there and also you get stuck in
traffic sir nobody you don't want to
work and help looking at it and I'm just
like you know that could happen because
I think when they do those billboards
it's not just the one sheet that they
create some right wool suit yeah let's
let's get past season one I understand
yeah but you know you gotta throw these
things out there you do so going back to
what you were saying though what look at
myself on the billboard right again
growing up in the family that you just
talked about yeah we grew up in that
whole world right we grew up with
everyone knowing who your family is we
course up with seeing your parents
everywhere so yes it's course it's
exciting but it's not I don't know
like I haven't even seen a billboard yet
because if they're all me some live on I
live in Brentwood so I'll show you what
there's one right by Taco Bell
I know I know well Lindsay Lindsay today
texted me went on son there's one on
Sunset either huge one outside yeah I
took photos of them you do yeah I gotta
go see it yeah yeah I take photos do we
already
are there any other any buses buses I've
never seen a bus no but I'm gonna ask
you how do people even gonna know to
watch it I don't know
I mean ABC but by the way ABC's been
promoting [ __ ] out of Oscars I know the
Oscars yeah it's all over a be seated
yeah was another lor like tired they're
like oh I see another one of these like
I know I know
yeah we're doing the Oscars that helped
me out a lot oh yeah because they put
they put oh yeah they put me in that
trail oh yeah that's a long one it was a
long one right and when I went to the
Comedy Store the next row was it I had
so many were little revenge shots oh
yeah real that people that I'm good at
I'm not gonna name names yeah but
there's a couple of people that don't
talk to me normally why because they're
above it why don't they talk to me
they're bigger than yeah they're bigger
than okay right they're busy right right
not that they're mean do you try to talk
to them well I mean you make an effort
yes I do what I do is do I lock eyes
yeah and then sometimes they do this
they when you lock eyes they just kind
of look away right that's my sign to go
oh maybe they're nervous about seeing
you know because ever since then the
lock eyes and then they smile and they
walk toward me mmm that's happening now
yes really in their life oh man you know
I know it's fake it's so sick it's check
and faked and discussed it yeah but
still of course it does of course it's a
little bit of a revenge
[Music]